today's topic i got a little surprise
for you you had a surprise for me
uh my issue with the the whole uh idea
of high value mail
is the people who usually you know
are looking for high value people in
their life i think your focus should
honestly be yourself
right you want to live a certain
lifestyle you want the lamborghini
lifestyle
um you should work for it um before you
look for in a partner
you should be high level yourself i
understand if someone makes 100k a year
and they want a partner that does the
same um
that's level playing field i understand
that um you don't want to have a partner
that drags you down financially or
anything
but if you're making 20k a year you have
three children you come to me
and you expect me to want to be with you
and i have options
with people i i think are higher valued
it's not going to happen are you are you
are you high value
i'm not good yeah i think so you know
yeah how much money you want to
no i never say no to that question give
me a ball range
uh when you talk about finances that's
my other issue i think
what's the other issue what are you
talking about you are a high value man
no i'm not middle range i'm middle range
i'm honest enough to admit i'm not
like in the highest okay i'm sorry i'm
sorry if you if you're not in the top
percentiles
okay finance you can't be probably i'm
not asking you see this is my other
problem no no no no
no no this is my other problem okay all
these guys who follow kevin saying was
like yeah you're not ready for a high
value man
a bunch of [ __ ] not high value man
either let's be honest
what's your statute of high value then
what was here bro you
you look at me look me dead in the eyes
and tell me that with your
income you are a high value man let me
look at me and i just say that [ __ ]
see here's the thing exactly
here's the thing the way my bank account
is set up
the way that things when i receive my
paycheck you know this is the thing
that was a yes no question that was a
real simple yes no question
i agree when kevin samuel says you know
the thing with a high value because
that's how it functions
and a lot of people that agree with that
like yeah i'm high value you're
they're not oh no no a lot of the dudes
will be in the comment section being
like
yay uh you a single mom you don't
deserve no high value man
i would never get like [ __ ] you're
middle class it's okay you don't need to
get so loud about it
okay most of those dudes who are making
that kind of income or not in comment
sections
or showing up to every life to get
excited to you know i mean
see a lady get dunked on so when i see a
lot of these dudes i mean chuckling they
talking about like
yeah it was a high value man it's like
bro you make 40k
you're average and it's okay but it's
like here's the thing okay about the
whole high value thing and being able to
exercise
options exercising options comes with
responsibilities
right even like islam when you have
multiple wives
you couldn't be a broke man and have
multiple times be careful you have to be
they say if you want to take on the
extra wives you have to be able to
finance them
so a lot of you broke as people who out
here talk about how about
that just make sure you put the barbecue
sauce in the bag all right mcdonald's
boys like stop playing with me
okay yeah yeah high value how about you
know what else is high value that
barbecue sauce [ __ ] don't forget it
stop playing oh can i get some napkins
too yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah i thought girls talk
about i'ma get with a man who makes more
than seven figures
i couldn't be caught dead being with you
at a restaurant for high value people
out you're embarrassing me you don't
even know how to use your cutlery like
stop oh look at this they got like a big
spoon and that's a little spoon what's
that for what
why you got you got too many spoon on
this table god damn
why you got so many forks yeah you ever
take a broke person out to some place
and they don't know how to act
no i don't play that
i don't play that hey listen you know
from one high value man to another
meaning preach not you guys to worry
are we high value
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah yeah
the same way some of these ladies live
in delusion and think they don't get
like this seven figure dude and all
those other nonsense
a lot of y'all live in delusion and
overestimate your worth
right that's part of the human
experience right one of the biggest
telltale signs of the human experience
is that we far overestimate our own
sense of self-worth
to the point of like delusion right and
that's good for us in some ways it helps
us overachieve
but for a lot of people you just look
crazy and stupid right
this doesn't make sense exactly when
michael jordan was a kid he said i'm
gonna be the best basketball player
everyone's like
crazy yeah you crazy right it's like
everybody for every michael jack
jordan all right there's a hundred other
ordinary [ __ ] and for every michael
jackson
there's a hundred thousands of kids
nah nah you know don't even play with
michael like that michael never did
anything
he all right but no no you know
michael jokes slide it's just it makes
me laugh when i see a lot of this stuff
yeah because i still agree with the high
value system and then the way it works
it's like that it's just a depiction the
person saying
that about the high value system doesn't
mean that he believes on or enforces
that
that's how the world works people want
high value
and you're not going to get that if your
average average you know what
people get really um they get they get
very vexed
or they find it cringe when they hear
things like high value and
lower value the reality is the world
understand why
yeah yeah because i think people don't
like the idea of hierarchies existing in
the world
within they don't like the idea of tier
systems exactly the reality is these
things we're all human beings we're all
equal
no it's not true okay the rule it's not
the same rules for everyone that's why
people who make more money
live by a different set of rules right
that's why people will make more money
some of them pay taxes others don't
right there's a whole bunch of different
stratospheres in this world
right some of you guys will never know a
whole range of experiences because
you're financially priced out
you will never know privileges in your
life the way some people from higher
socioeconomic backgrounds don't
like the idea of like here's a weird one
the more money you make the cheaper
everything becomes
that's weird right and and same thing
when you become famous
if i become famous and i got more money
i'm the one that shouldn't be able to be
that that should pay for my [ __ ] but
because i'm famous because i got money
i walked to a spot oh here this is under
the house whoa whoa
why you just have a youtube channel
you're not famous exactly my point
it shouldn't be that and even with that
people are like yeah
on their house and i'm like well i
should pay for that i mean thank you but
but yeah the the more money you got that
privilege that he's describing
isn't evidence of hierarchy the idea
that if you are
at a certain level whether it be finance
looks wise whatever
you are treated differently and that's
because we recognize that as having a
perceived value
so whether kevin samuel says it whether
we say it or whether everyone abolishes
the term
it has zero bearing on the fact that
these hierarchies exist ladies also know
this like all these ladies say i don't
like this term high value
ladies most of y'all will avoid men who
exist in the top stratosphere
because of your insecurities you know
that too many women are vying for these
men
right because of the fact that they're
up there in terms of like
being wanted so what happens you guys go
for people that are what
on a lower tier because they're more
accessible more security in that you're
still doing that so so it's like
we all know these things exist you've
known who the pretty lady in your class
was
you knew she got treated differently you
also know how other people get treated
differently
so it just strikes me as odd when people
are like others high value it's like
yeah not everything about your sense of
worth
is tied to how much money you make i'll
agree
but in our world and in a lot of
people's lives
money is very important it's extremely
important and sometimes
fame is more important because a doctor
is not going to walk in a restaurant and
be like i'm a doctor
i save life every day and get a free
meal
i might sometimes it's fine
sometimes it's money but at the end of
the day
there's still a hierarchy yeah so that's
what these terms are there to
illustrate and i think it's just
important for a lot of people to know
just because you're not on the top you
know on the top layer or you're on top
of the hierarchy
doesn't mean that you can't have a good
life i think too many people want to
live in delusion so
yeah this call just made me laugh this
man was all hanging on about like high
value
i was like bro i'm always gonna say yes
to that question yeah but you're not
really answering the question of how
much you make
so we can know that you're about not so
issue or issues
[Music]
why you wanna be a player